let me just say this we are proud that  we fought for our values proud that we  fought for our values our values in New  York City are to defend working men and  women labor unions the rights of men and  women to organize to fight for their  jobs men and women who want to work and  we're fighting for immigrants  yes Amazon works with ice proudly works  with ice to terrorize immigrants and we  decided that we wanted to stand and  fight once again on behalf of the rights  of immigrants in New York City and in  this country because just because some  people want to make more money it's  still important to fight for immigrants  in this city and in this country  [Music]